ravie de vous accueillir dans cette
salle qui n'est pas d'un grand confort
pour des raisons absolument
indépendantes de notre volonté qui
tiennent au lifting que subit la façade
à la retransmission qui nous oblige
obscurcir la pièce mais je suis sûr que
tout se passera très bien en tout cas je
voulais vraiment vous remercier
d'être venu ce matin au Sénat pour pour
cet échange donc dans le cadre d'une
table ronde sur un sujet qui non
seulement d'actualité
mais qui est extrêmement extrêmement
important et il est important pour deux
choses puisque on est dans cette
transition écologique où la question des
énergies est une question qui devient
structurelle et enfin nous le savons et
dans le projet de loi de finance nous
avons tenté
au Sénat en tout cas d'intervenir pour
essayer d'adoucir l'inflation qui est
subie par les collectivités
territoriales par la hausse du coup e de
l'énergie qui est un vrai sujet donc on
sait que la fin de l'année 2021 avec ce
contexte que j'ai évoqué et le début de
la guerre en Ukraine
il y a eu un impact très important
puisque il était chiffré à 15 milliards
sur les collectivités
en année pleine donc nous avons en 2022
engagés ce travail sur les coûts de
l'énergie l'incidence sur les
collectivités territoriales alors que
même s'il y a eu des mesures qui ont été
mises en place sur le filet de sécurité
etc sur lequel on expliquera sans doute
nos amis un certain nombre de
réserves des dispositions de les
collectivités aux prises pour diminuer
leurs dépenses en énergie
se trouve que nous étions tout à fait
conscients de l'impact de hausse subie
incontournable et brutal qui n'est plus
être anticipé pour les collectivités
donc nous avons matérialisé cet
engagement au travers d'un rapport qui
était publié le 27 juillet 2022 donc
avant même que nous parlions du projet
de loi de finances rapports qui
s'appelait les collectivités
territoriales face à la hausse du coût
de l'énergie il s'agissait de
sensibiliser on va dire l'ensemble des
parlementaires mais aussi le Parlement
à l'incident ce qui allait devoir être
supporté sur le budget 2022 et notamment
2023 nous avons également réalisé une
consultation près des élus locaux de
concert avec la commission des finances
pour éclairer ce débat en loi de finance
il y a un peu plus de 1200 élus qui ont
participé et qui nous ont à la fois
parlé de leurs inquiétudes et surtout
des dispositions qu'ils allaient prendre
pour essayer d'atténuer le choc parce
que nous savons que les élus locaux sont
plutôt inventeurs de solutions que
sources de problèmes et qu'ils essaient
à chaque fois d'avoir des réponses
intelligentes entre guillemets y compris
au hausse qui se qui s'impose
brutalement
et sans avoir été choisi donc 6 mesures
ont été mises en place on a vu une
diminution de la part d'assis sur
l'électricité un bouclier de tarifaire
un amortisseur électricité un filet de
sécurité une charte avec les
fournisseurs et un prix de référence
nous mesurons en 2023 l'effet sur les
collectivités de ces dispositifs ce que
nous savons que
l'aide apportée par des mesures
gouvernementales ou législatives est
liée
aux résultats du compte administratif
qui est connu à peu près en ce moment
nous verrons l'impact réel de ces
dispositions et puis nous avons souhaité
élargir le champ d'investigation aux
autres approvisionnements des
collectivités puisque la fonction de la
délégation et d'essayer de de recueillir
les bonnes pratiques les pistes
d'évolution que vous choisissez les uns
et les autres pour les diffuser et
parfois
comme nous pouvons quand c'est
nécessaire surtout les utiliser
pour les intégrer dans des dispositifs
législatifs donc je suis très heureuse
d'accueillir madame Récréo qui est
directrice du marché d'affaires à la
direction commerce d'électricité de
France donc EDF monsieur jossa qui est
président de l'Union des groupements
d'achats publics on a vu comment les
groupements d'achat devenacer
déterminants pour essayer de palier
là-haut de l'énergie et Monsieur Leyens
berger qui est mère de Saverne et
Monsieur Philippon ourrasque qui est
président du Syndicat national de la
restauration collective parce que nous
savons aussi l'impact
l'impact de ce volet énergie sur la
restauration collective
impact auquel il faut rajouter celui de
la hausse des matières premières
alimentaires
et de l'inflation donc chacun avec votre
point de vue et c'est l'intérêt de votre
diversité si je puis dire vous nous
livrez vous ne ferez pas de la manière
dont vos collectivités approchent les
choses dans ce contexte inflationniste
que nous connaissons et puis surtout
nous nous sommes déjà si je puis dire
non seulement en analyse de ce qu'on a
pu et en évaluation de ce que les
collectivités alors comment ont pu subir
depuis 2022 mais nous allons entrer dans
la période de préparation budgétaire
nous avons ici quelques collègues des
commissions de des Finances qui seront
assez attentifs à ce que vous direz
parce qu'il y aura sans doute des
dispositifs mis en place
dans la loi de finance 2023 faire
évoluer je ne serai pas plus longue
sachant que nous disposons
du temps que nous souhaitons mais
jusqu'à 10 heures
voilà parce que nous avons un bateau à
prendre ce qui paraît curieux mais pas
ici mais à Brest n'est-ce pas parce que
nous partons à Ouessant je voyais
l'étonnement de tout le monde je ne
serai pas
merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames laissées
natrices messieurs les sénateurs merci
pour votre invitation cette audition qui
me donne l'occasion de m'exprimer sur
ces sujets importants je le sais pour
les pour les collectivités alors comme
vous l'avez vous l'avez indiqué je ne
vais pas m'apesantir vous en avez déjà
parlé nous avons connu une tendance
haussière des prix de l'énergie des prix
du gaz qui a entraîné à sa suite une
hausse des prix de l'électricité parce
que vous savez le gaz et le sous-jacent
le plus important des prix de
l'électricité sur les marchés de gros en
réalité cette hausse elle a commencé en
de manière beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
moins importante qu'en 2022 mais elle a
commencé en 2021 avec la reprise
économique post covid et puis elle s'est
accentuée en 2022 avec évidemment
l'invasion de de l'Ukraine par la Russie
alors ceci a induit des hausses très
importantes comme on le sait sur en fait
ce qu'on appelle le forward c'est à dire
le prix à terme vu en 2022 pour 2023 et
donc cela impacté fortement les les
factures les prix des consommateurs donc
collectivités et entreprises pour ce qui
concerne mon marché donc pour 2023 alors
pour ceux qui ont contractualisé
effectivement dans la dans la période
j'allais dire au pire moment
c'est-à-dire au second semestre 2023 ce
qui avait pris position ou
contractualisé auparavant évidemment eu
moins de moins d'effets sur leur facture
alors suite à cela les pouvoirs publics
ont mis en place les mesures dont vous
avez parlé madame la Présidente donc si
vous avez des questions précises j'y
reviendrai ensuite bien sûr je ne vais
pas les détailler là mais en effet vous
avez le bouclier le bouclier tarifaire
le bouclier électricité le
suremortisseur pour les TPE et acteurs
publics assimilés à des TPE et puis
l'amortisseur pour toutes les
collectivités
ces mesures ces aides passent par la
facture des fournisseurs en effet et
puis le filet de sécurité qui qui
s'additionne qui est direct entre l'État
et les collectivités où là nous les
fournisseurs on ne le on ne le connaît
pas on ne le voit pas alors peut-être
deux mots sur la façon dont nous avons
accompagné nos clients collectivités
comme entreprise d'ailleurs de temps en
temps je dirais entreprise parce que je
sais que les territoires sont très
attentifs aux entreprises qui qui se
situent sur leur territoire donc nous
avons accompagné nos clients en
particulier collectivités dans cette
période en par trois grandes sections au
niveau des aides donc la première le
premier ensemble d'actions c'était une
phase des actions de d'explication parce
que évidemment ce dispositif il est très
très utile bien évidemment mais quand
même assez complexe donc du coup il a
fallu effectivement pas mal expliqué et
donc les équipes dans les régions vous
savez qu'on est on est situé sur
l'ensemble du territoire et c'est
d'ailleurs un point extrêmement
important pour nous que d'être en
proximité de nos clients sur l'ensemble
du territoire on participait à
énormément de réunions plusieurs
plusieurs dizaines voire même plus de
plus de 100 réunion organisée par les
préfets souvent auxquels beaucoup de
collectivités étaient présentes
d'ailleurs et donc pour expliquer les
mesures nous avons mis en place une
ligne dédiée sur nos plateaux relations
clients nous avons mis en place une page
web dédiée sur notre site et également
une calculette qui est toujours à
l'oeuvre d'ailleurs sur notre site pour
simuler les aides donc deuxième ensemble
de d'actions il a fallu recueillir les
attestations des éligibilité parce que
comme vous le savez il fallait attester
les clients devaient les consommateurs
devaient attester sur l'honneur qu'il
faisait partie de tel ou telle catégorie
pour avoir droit aux différentes aides
que j'ai citées
pour recueillir les attestations les
traiter si possible automatiquement et
pour les pour pour prononcer leur
conformité et pouvoir appliquer les
aides ça a été un gros travail et puis
troisième action évidemment très
importante ça a été de faire évoluer le
système d'information et la facture hier
pour pouvoir inclure les aides dans les
factures alors ça a l'air de rien comme
ça vous dites bon finalement c'est une
ligne avec un signe moins dans la
facture ouais sauf que c'est plus
compliqué que ça parce qu'il faut
modifier le système d'information il
faut faire les calculs il y a des cas
les cas sont très différents les uns des
autres bon bref un ensemble de de
travaux
réalisés dans un temps extrêmement
contraint et donc maintenant on est nous
sommes dans la phase où effectivement
les factures sortent avec avec les aides
alors ça ça a été la phase de mise en
oeuvre et puis maintenant si on se
projette un petit peu dans l'avenir
alors vous avez parlé de la suite
nous ne savons pas ce que deviendront
éventuellement dans ces aides en 24 ou
en 25 ce que a indiqué le gouvernement
c'est que le bouclier tarifaire serait
prolongé jusqu'à 2000-2025 mais pour les
autres aides nous ne le savons pas nous
verrons
s'agissant des prix alors comme vous le
savez enfin je ne serai pas surpris si
je vous dis que nous n'avons pas de
boule de cristal et que nous ne pouvons
pas indiquer comment les prix de marché
vont évoluer bien évidemment aujourd'hui
l'horizon côté il est à trois ans donc
on sait que les prix ont commencé à
baisser si on se projette sur 24 25 26
le forward donc de l'électricité sur sur
24 aujourd'hui il navigue autour de 150
euros du mégawattheure à peu près alors
il est encore assez volatile il était à
120 parfois il monte à 160 disons autour
de 150
2025 on est autour de 120 et 206 autour
de 100 mais au-delà de ça on peut pas
dire grand chose ce qu'on peut dire en
revanche c'est qu'il y a comme vous le
savez un travail au niveau de l'Union
européenne sur ce qu'on appelle le
Market design c'est-à-dire l'évolution
de la de la façon dont le marché va
fonctionner
cette ce travail au niveau de l'Union
européenne qui doit normalement se
terminer cette année si j'ai bien
compris à deux grands objectifs auxquels
EDF ne peut que souscrire le premier
objectif c'est d'apporter de la de la
visibilité et de la stabilité surtout
aux consommateurs c'est à dire faire en
sorte qu'il ne soit pas violemment
impacté par les les fluctuations telles
qu'on a connu sur le sur les marchés de
gros alors en tant que EDF en tant que
commercialisateur évidemment est
favorable à cet objectif second objectif
de l'Union européenne c'est de donner de
la visibilité aux producteurs quel qu'il
soit renouvelables nucléaire etc pour
pour investir dans l'avenir dans la
transition énergétique et évidemment EDF
EN tant que producteur cette fois-ci ne
peut que souscrire à cet objectif bien
évidemment nous avons besoin d'investir
et donc nous avons besoin de visibilité
alors au-delà de ça on ne sait pas très
bien encore quel mécanisme sera mis en
place puisque de plus en France vous le
savez fin 2025 la reine se termine et
donc nous verrons quel dispositif sera
mis en place aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
nous suivons effectivement ces
travaux
je terminerai mon propos liminaire par
un point qui est extrêmement important
selon nous c'est tout ce qui est
sobriété efficacité énergétique alors
c'est un sujet dont on parle qu'on
pratique depuis fort longtemps que les
collectivités pratiquent depuis
longtemps les entreprises aussi bien sûr
ce n'est pas nouveau je suis pas du tout
en train de dire que c'est une
découverte mais dans une période où le
prix de l'électricité est très élevé où
les factures sont élevées même si elles
ont été amorties par les aides bien
évidemment mais enfin quand même ça
reste assez élevé et puis de toute façon
ces vertueux d'un point de vue d'un
point de vue des carbonation notamment
et bien et bien ça devient encore plus
important parce que le temps de retour
sur investissement des travaux
d'efficacité énergétique de
se réduit considérablement dans cette
période alors là évidemment nous
accompagnons tous nos clients et
notamment les collectivités dans ce dans
cette démarche et c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment un point extrêmement important
alors je vais juste citer pour terminer
deux trois éléments d'abord des outils
de compréhension de la consommation
parce que on ne peut agir que si on
comprend sa consommation donc on
visualise ces consommations et on
analyse comment on consomme comment nos
clients consomment pour pour ensuite
agir au bon endroit
un accompagnement au travers des
certificats d'économie d'énergie ça
c'est extrêmement important parce
qu'effectivement cela permet d'aider à
l'investissement nous nous produisons
directement des certificats d'économie
d'énergie auprès de nos clients ou de
nos partenaires et puis nous finançons
nous nous finançons un certain nombre de
grands programmes je pensais par exemple
qui qui
favorise la rénovation des bâtiments et
qui et qui produisent des c'est qui
permettent de produire des C2E donc ce
sont des programmes importants auprès
des collectivités des territoires et
puis nous avons toutes nos filiales qui
qui effectivement accompagnent donc les
clients dans leur dans leurs actions
comme par exemple Dalkia pour les
certificats les pardon les contrats de
performance énergétique ou bien dans le
dans la région Ouest électricité de
Strasbourg avec sa filiale de service
énergétique nous avons nous avons
également je voudrais souligner pour
terminer le renouvelable avec des fenr
qui proposent des des solutions
d'autoconsommation pourquoi j'en parle
parce que en fait
disposer d'une solution
d'autoconsommation de photovoltaïques
sur ces toitures ou ses ombrières de
parking voir sur le sol ça ne fait pas
consommer moins bien sûr en revanche
cela permet de consommer une partie de
sa de sa consommation de cela de
produire soi-même et de la et de la
consommer localement la produire et la
consommer localement donc au niveau prix
c'est très intéressant parce que cela
donne une visibilité sur le prix dans la
durée sur cette portion là de
consommation donc même au niveau du prix
c'est intéressant donc c'est quelque
chose qui le qu'il faut auquel il faut
penser et donc notre filiale EDF
accompagne les clients en ce sens
également voilà donc un volet
extrêmement important dans cette période
de prix élevé me semble me semble-t-il
ou madame j'ai peut-être passé la parole
à Monsieur jossa donc vous vous
représentez luga pendant
quelques heures ces deux mots étaient de
trop et vous allez nous parler des
groupements d'achats qui ont attiré
particulièrement notre attention
au moment de cette hausse du coût de
l'énergie
merci Madame à la présidente
bien évidemment
totalement en vue dans l'expérience
professionnelle passée j'ai parfaitement
conscience du choc ça a été pour les
collectivités territoriales sur leur
budget de fonctionnement mais aussi de
manière induite sur leur budget
d'investissement de voir le coût de
l'énergie perturbé de manière aussi
importante leur programmation et leur
exécution budgétaire voilà alors
comme je vais pas revenir sur les causes
de séance de l'énergie ma collègue par
un certainement bien mieux que moi mais
simplement insister sur un des
caractéristiques du marché de l'énergie
c'est que c'est un des marchés c'est une
activité de marché et c'est une activité
où c'est unique l'offre doit s'adapter
mais instantanément à la demande c'est
une particularité et à la seconde près
voilà donc c'est une des particularités
de cette activité de marché ce qui fait
d'ailleurs que le marché de l'énergie 1
est à et forcément et partout dans le
monde une activité de marché même si il
y a une marge manœuvre pour ceux qui
produisent eux-mêmes leur énergie et
d'autre part c'est un c'est un marché où
les prix s'ajuste au coût marginal
c'est-à-dire au coût de la l'énergie la
plus coûteuse qu'on est obligée de
mettre en production tout simplement
parce que quand vous décidez d'activer
une centrale thermique et bien le prix
c'est celui qui permet de couvrir le
coude de la centrale thermique c'est
bien pour ça que les prix du gaz
rétroagis sur les prix de l'électricité
et comme ça un marché qui se régule
instantanément bien et que la produit
est que l'offre n'a aucune moyen aucun
moyen de maîtriser la demande et bien ça
peut provoquer en cas de circonstances
exceptionnelle une très forte Valo Donat
il était des prix et toute la difficulté
du sujet que qu'on a traité c'est de
d'adapter à les collectivités locales
mais aussi d'autres consommateurs qui
recherchent la stabilité quelque chose
qui est instintre un segment et
structurellement volatile et la
difficulté évidemment je reviendrai pas
sur les phénomènes exceptionnels la
conjonction de la croissance de la
guerre en Ukraine des difficultés les
centrales nucléaires qui ont fait que
tout ça arrive en même moment ça
provoqué c'est c'est choc considérables
que nous connaissons tous voilà ce que
donc ce que je puisque
le rôle des commercialisateurs que sont
les centrales d'achat je pense qu'il
faut venir sur une des caractéristiques
de de marché de l'énergie qui il y a
deux éléments dans le prix qui est payé
et de part par le client final il y a le
coût généré brut de l'énergie et
deuxièmement il y en a rémunération de
l'intermédiation voilà donc choisissons
du coup brut de l'énergie comme vous le
savez c'est un marché dans laquelle il y
a
généralement les achats se font un an
deux ans à l'avance et puis là justement
il y a forcément justement puisque il
faut régler comme comme je l'ai dit la
consommation
au jour le jour se fait sur le marché
qu'on appelle le marché spot et
effectivement tous ces marchés comme
comme les marchés financiers se régulent
en fonction de l'offre et de la demande
de l'anticipation de ce qu'on va être
les coûts futures voilà quand voilà donc
ça c'est une des structures de de ce
domaine et
et ceci influe donc sur le coup de
l'énergie donc quand vous évaluez donc
un élément qui est très important il
faut prendre en compte comme l'essentiel
des achats se font en achat à terme
quand vous évaluez la performance d'un
fournisseur il faut avoir conscience
qu'une partie du sujet est liée au
moment où lui-même est allé sur le
marché donc vous pouvez dire tiens
pourquoi un tel est plus cher que qu'un
autre ça dépend aussi du moment où
lui-même c'est étalé sur le marché donc
si tu allais plutôt en ce moment ça a
été plutôt mieux mais en période
baissière ça va être différent donc il
faut faire attention à ne pas juger
complètement les les intermédiaires sur
le monsieur sur les prix qui sont en
mesure de vous proposer de ce que ça
dépend donc encore une fois de leur
stratégie d'achat qui peut être bonne
qui peut être mauvaise qui peut être
spéculative et quand spécule on peut
gagner on peut perdre d'ailleurs
certains noms de fournisseurs
intermédiaires ont cruellement perdu il
y en a un ou deux qui sont sortis du
marché à cause de ça et on en fait
quelque chose à Lucas parce qu'on était
notamment travaillé avec un fournisseur
alternatif qui a fait faillite voilà
donc
en général l'objectif c'est quand même
de limiter la spéculation comme comme
dans ce domaine comme dans d'autres
c'est-à-dire que l'acheteur se couvre
euh en achetant un terme justement de
manière à éviter les risques et un des
sujets que nous on a et qu'on souhaite
c'est que il y a une plus grande
sécurité implique grande surveillance
notamment des fournisseurs alternatives
parce qu'on a eu on a vu quelques excès
dans ce domaine qui ont fini par coûter
cher voilà
de la même manière il faut pas penser
que forcément si vous achetez dans dans
l'achat en plus dans la structure de
d'achat vous pouvez quand vous allez sur
un marché tout acheter d'un quand vous
passez des commandes publiques vous
pouvez vous-même c'est un superpose la
commande publique au marché de
l'électricité vous vous partez en
commande public en achetant un prix et
là aussi vous pouvez soit tout acheter
d'un coup en exigeant un prix fixe soit
vous pouvez avoir des dispositifs qui
vous permettent de demander de mettre en
concurrence les opérateurs sur leur
marge et leur demander d'aller au marché
un certain moment de manière à lisser un
peu le risque c'est ce qu'on la
stratégie multiclic pour les
spécialistes du sujet pour avoir
confiance que si l'Acheteur exige
d'aller à coût fixe d'un coup sur la
totalité de la période ça donne beaucoup
de visibilité mais il y a aussi un côté
spéculatif parce que si vous faites ça
vous pensez que vous avez un bon prix au
moins vous achetez mais si les prix
baisses vous aurez vous serez mauvais
donc nous notre stratégie de ce point de
vue là c'est de lisser des achats et
donc on a une stratégie multiclic qui
fait que lorsqu'on achète pour l'année
prochaine on fait 10 qu'on demande à
l'opérateur d'opérer en dix fois des
moments qu'on indique avec lorsqu'on
dépasse on baisse un son de seuil à la
hausse à la baisse de manière à lisser
un peu le risque donc ça peut dire que à
certains moments le prix de l'énergie
que nous vendons peut être soit meilleur
soit moins bon mais en fait on essaye
quand même de suivre la réalité du
marché en lissant un peu le risque pour
les entités clientes et
le dernier point voilà voilà donc c'est
un peu cette stratégie en tout cas
potentiel que nous on essaye d'avoir à
l'UGAP de manière à maîtriser ses coûts
le deuxième composant du coup c'est la
rémunération du fournisseur alors il y a
un point qui qu'il faut avoir en
conscience sur la compétitivité des
intermédiaires il y a trois éléments qui
sont décisifs le l'opérateur il doit
couvrir ses sons et donc à trois
éléments qui sont importants c'est
d'avoir une courbe de consommation la
plus plate possible parce que comme vous
savez le coup de la consommation est
très variable donc si vous arrivez sur
le marché avec une courbe de
consommation de certitude que vous avez
des clients qui ont une courbe de
consommation plate c'est quelque chose
qui vous permet d'obtenir un meilleur
prix ça veut dire qu'il faut que vous
ayez un portefeuille de clients qui ne
consomme pas tous au même moment et donc
il est intéressant d'avoir dans un
portefeuille de clients des clients
contracycliques par exemple des
syndicats hydrauliques ou des gens qui
se consomment beaucoup d'énergie l'été
au contrebalancer ceux qui demande
beaucoup l'hiver ça c'est le sujet
d'avoir un cours plate le deuxième enjeu
c'est d'avoir
de pouvoir attribuer ça c'est spécifique
qu'elle a commande publique plus
rapidement possible parce que quand
votre fournisseur s'engage auprès de
vous il va chercher sur l'électricité
sur le marché et c'est un marché
extrêmement volatile et même la période
entre le moment où vous avez
soumissionne et le moment où le marché
est attribué il y a un risque et donc
nous avons par exemple réduit la durée
des traditions strict minimum on biz une
heure entre le moment on met sur le
marché et une ou deux heures et donc
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai totalement délégué la signature de
marché dans ce domaine à la personne qui
qui attribue de manière pourra faire ça
instantanée c'est important pour limiter
le risque sur un marché qui fluctue mais
même au sein de ma journée et le
troisième élément qui est essentiel
c'est d'avoir une courbe la plus fiable
possible parce que plus la courbe est
fiable moins les gens ont besoin d'aller
sur le marché spot et de couvrir des
risques on a vu un fournisseur
alternatif qui était en difficulté
simplement et c'était correctement
couvert mais simplement les écarts entre
les prévisions et ce qu'il était obligé
de fournir faisait qu'il était obligé
d'aller à un moment où les prix étaient
très hauts il a perdu beaucoup d'argent
donc cette fiabilité elle a un coût
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes assez exigeants sur le fait que
lorsqu'une collectivité sanguinge auprès
de nous c'est un engagement ferme et et
un peu irrévocable parce que c'est ce
qui permet d'avoir la fiabilité des
coûts et c'est tout ceci qui nous permet
de réduire au maximum nos coûts de
production voilà ce que je voulais dire
sur le bien acheter de trois mots de
réflexion sur les mêmes si je suis pas
totalement compétent sur les solutions
qui sont envisagées je crois que comme
beaucoup d'autres que vous avez entendu
la meilleure solution c'est d'abord de
d'économiser l'énergie la meilleure
économie c'est non consommé
et de ce point de vue là en tout cas
nous on a beaucoup investi un peu comme
mes collègues sur l'accompagnement en
termes de conseils et nous avons une
offre de politique énergétique et de
maîtrise énergétique des conseils qui se
développe et qui qui est en pleine
progression notamment dans le domaine de
les politiques énergétiques locales donc
le gars pas beaucoup investi sur ses
missions de conseil de manière à mieux
maîtriser l'énergie des bâtiments et
puis généralement la politique
énergétique des collectivités locales
c'est fondamentales dans la durée il y a
l'autocom son consommation d'en parler
ma voisine il y a aussi les PPA les
Power purching agrements qui sont des
accords principalement fondés sur le
voltaïque et éléonien dans lequel vous
pouvez avoir un préfixe sur une période
de 10 à 15 ans comme c'est de la
production comme c'est de la production
ça dépend pas des fluctuations les
marchés donc on peut avoir un préfixe il
y a quand même une contrepartie dans
contrat qui est que plus vous faites de
faute photovoltaïques et derrière le
lien plus votre enfin vous pouvez pas
tout prendre là dessus c'est en moyenne
10 à 15% de votre production mais le
fauteuil voltaïque et l'éolien ont comme
caractéristiques d'être une ressource
dans la quantité est incertaine ça
dépend du vent ça dépend du soleil donc
vous allez oublier d'aller vous êtes
obligé d'aller sur le marché sur le
reste et vous arrivez avec une courbe de
consommation qui est beaucoup plus
incertaine et ceci peut avoir un coût
pour la collectivité locale qui recouvre
assez ces solutions voilà donc dans les
autres solutions bon je crois que bon je
vais pas intervenir sur le sujet de la
réintroduction du tarifs réglementé
parce que c'est un sujet qui dépasse
complètement ma compétence je dirais
simplement que lorsque le prix est
réglementé s'éloigne du prix du marché
ben il faut qu'il y a quelqu'un qui paye
soit c'est le producteur soit c'est
l'intermédiaire soit c'est le
contribuable mais c'est forcément aller
chercher de l'argent ailleurs que sur le
marché voilà j'irai pas plus loin sur ce
sujet là il y a le sujet du plafond à
Rennes qui arrivent à expiration qui qui
va donner lieu à débat mais difficile
comme l'a dit ma collègue de découpler
ce débat sur ce qui va se passer sur le
Market design de la commission parce que
les deux sujets sont intrinsèquement
liés donc je n'irai pas beaucoup plus
loin sur ce sujet voilà je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Monsieur le Maire
de Saverne
votre histoire nous intéresse et je vais
dire beaucoup aussi merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs je vous remercie de me donner
la possibilité de porter la voix des des
villes de taille moyenne qui sont et
vous le savez bien les moteurs de nos
territoires Saverne est une ville de
12000 habitants en Alsace au sein d'une
comme comme qui fait 36000 habitants
mais elle a elle est aussi la ville
centre d'un territoire beaucoup plus
vaste c'est à peu près 150 000 personnes
qui vivent directement de la centralité
de Saverne ce qui signifie que nous
avons des obligations de centralité très
forts avec les recettes d'une ville de
12000 habitants ce qui est parfois
difficile à gérer déjà dans des
situations normales un budget de
fonctionnement de 16 millions d'euros 90
000 m² de bâtiment à chauffer à éclairer
70 km de voirie à entretenir et à
éclairer ce qui fait que bien évidemment
lorsque l'on doit faire face à
l'explosion des coûts de l'énergie
ceci est effectivement un choc pour
reprendre l'expression de monsieur le
Président il y a quelques instants ça
ajoute à cela pour nous une conjoncture
compliquée parce que nous faisions
madame parti des communes qui arrivent à
échéance de notre contrat d'électricité
au 31 décembre dernier nous avons donc
eu renouveler notre appel d'offres nous
n'avons eu qu'un seul
participant à cette appel d'offres
l'électricité de Strasbourg votre
filiale et on se retrouve aujourd'hui
avec un coût de l'énergie multipliée par
4 donc c'est quelque chose de
particulièrement compliqué à
amortir sans compter bien sûr
l'augmentation du coût du gaz qui lui
est davantage fluctuant à la fin de 2022
les services de de la commune on fait un
calcul si nous restions à une
consommation
identique de fluide aux années
précédentes nous en avions pour 1,6
millions d'euros de factures
supplémentaires soit 10% de notre budget
de fonctionnement quand on connaît les
taux de rigidité dans un dans un budget
communal on peut imaginer que une hausse
de 10 % ben ça veut dire
potentiellement mettre fin à toute une
série de politiques publiques de mon
côté avec avec notre équipe municipale
nous sommes refusés à cette absurdité
qui consisterait à à prélever l'impôt
pour uniquement payer des fluides et ne
plus mener de politique publique on
n'est pas là juste pour payer les
fluides évidemment et nous avons donc
des dès l'automne 2022 pris quelques
décisions drastiques pour un je dirais
un plan de sobriété renforcé d'abord des
mesures de bon sens que tout le monde
connaît effectivement la limitation de
la température dans dans nos bâtiments
la chasse au gaspi je peux vous dire que
le thermomètre est devenu mon meilleur
ami et on a souvent vu le maire de
moderne se promener jour et nuit
week-end compris dans les différents
bâtiments pour relever la température
pour baisser les les radiateurs et
épaisser contre celles et ceux qui ne
jouaient pas le jeu ça sert c'est pas
grand chose mais c'est enfin c'est des
petites choses mais c'est important mais
ça nous est pas paru suffisant puisque
nous avons également pris des mesures
exceptionnelles relativement drastique
nous avons dès le mois de septembre
décidé de couper l'éclairage public de
21h à 6h c'est drastique mais c'est
efficace 200.000 200000 euros d'économie
alors on avait déjà un peu d'avance
puisque ça fait 7 ans qu'on coupait
l'électricité à minuit on a gagné encore
un petit peu de temps avec quelques
grognements mais plutôt de la
compréhension de la part de nos de nos
administrés puisqu'on leur a promis
qu'en échange nous allons continuer nous
allions continuer à mener les politiques
culturelles sportives sociales
environnementales que nous étions
engagés à faire
nous avons également pris la décision
pour la première fois de fermer une
semaine entière les services publics
avec bien sûr quelques quelques
permanences pour certains services mais
entre entre Noël et Nouvel An et j'ai
pris la décision d'accorder 4 jours de
congés supplémentaires à mon personnel
le coût le le en tout cas la balance
entre le coup et le bénéfice nous est
apparu largement positive à ce niveau là
et bien entendu on n'a pas eu de
difficultés avec les syndicats sur sur
cette question là et la mesure sans
doute la plus spectaculaire et je pense
que sommes une des rares collectivités
allaient avoir prises c'est que nous
avons décidé de mettre en place pendant
l'hiver une semaine de quatre jours et
donc
de laisser les services publics ouverts
du lundi au jeudi de manière à pouvoir
couper enfin en tout cas baisser le
chauffage dès le jeudi après-midi et le
rallumer que dans la nuit du dimanche au
lundi bien sûr pas pour les écoles et
autres mais pour la principale pour les
principaux services publics alors les
résultats sont encourageants en tout cas
pour l'hiver on est en train de
finaliser les les calculs mais en gros
c'est entre 30 et 40 % d'économies sur
les volumes consommés que nous avons pu
faire durant durant cette cette période
là donc avec cette économie en volume
ajouté au base fiscal qui ont quand même
augmenté de manière importante de 7,1%
et nous l'espérons le l'amortisseur de
l'État mais là il y a encore pour nous
un point d'interrogation parce que à ce
jour nous estimons que nous sommes
éligibles à cet amortisseur fiscal et
nous en attendons 400 000 euros mais
pour l'instant tant que les choses ne
sont pas notifiées avec l'État moi je
serai plutôt comme saint Thomas je
préfère avoir vu avant de avant de le
croire mais en tout cas espérons en tout
cas si on
si on met en bout à bout ses efforts là
la hausse de des bases fiscales et
l'amortisseur de l'État je dirais que
pour l'instant on y arrive bon
normalement avec quelques efforts malgré
tout sur sur la sur le fonctionnement
mais cela fait toutefois peser des
risques sur notre capacité
d'autofinancement bien entendu puisque à
la hausse des coûts de l'énergie
s'ajoute bien sûr la housse des coûts
des matières premières des matériaux
notamment alors même que nous sommes
engagés dans un plan pluriannuel
d'investissement qu'il nous est pas
possible forcément de différer il y a un
certain nombre de travaux qui sont en
cours nous sommes en train de de
travailler sur le magnifique château des
Rohan mais ce sont c'est un un budget de
6,5 millions d'euros qui est engagé là
dessus avec bien sûr des subventions des
collectivités supérieures mais malgré
tout il faut faire face à la à la hausse
des des coûts et donc forcément une
certaine inquiétude pour l'avenir parce
qu'une capacité d'autofinancement qui se
dégrade avec en plus des taux d'intérêt
qui qui augmentent on peut être amené à
se demander quels vont être nos
capacités d'investissement également
dans dans les dans les années à venir
alors pour conclure je dirais quand en
étant réactif et en prenant des mesures
fortes on est capable en tout cas dans
une ville comme la comme la mienne de de
faire face à une situation
conjoncturelle mais si cette situation
devenait de venir davantage structurel
nos marges de manoeuvre s'en
trouveraient fortement réduite et avec
un grand point d'interrogation et ce
d'autant et je peux pas résister quand
même à le placer que bien sûr nos marges
fiscales sont devenues particulièrement
limitées à la seule taxe foncière ce que
je regrette profondément merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente merci beaucoup
Monsieur le Maire pour votre témoignage
qui contient quelques innovations
notamment autour de la semaine des
quatre jours je ne veux pas encore fait
le lien entre la crise de l'énergie la
semaine de quatre jours mais voilà c'est
voyez les mains autour des idées
innovantes assez originales merci
Monsieur on aura l'occasion d'en parler
au travers des questions de l'école
alors pouvons-nous parler maintenant
monsieur ponorin du sujet également très
important de la restauration collective
merci pour votre invitation alors
j'espère que je vais pas faire hors
sujet un évoquant la problématique de
l'alimentation au quotidien des Français
j'ai pas beaucoup parlé d'énergie mais
je vais parler plus de l'inflation des
matières premières notamment des
matières premières avec une part
importante de composantes agricoles à
l'intérieur de ces matières premières et
d'augmentation des salaires tout ça pour
finalement évoquer l'inflation que
connaît la restauration collective et
donc les collectivités locales
le SNRC sûrement moins connu que la
mairie de Saverne pour son col et pas
que et que EDF ou lugab donc en une
phrase le syndicat de sol de la
restauration collective réunit une
quarantaine d'entreprises de toutes
tailles vous avez des grands groupes des
PME des et des TPE qui maillent le
territoire national pour faire ce métier
que celui de la restauration collective
nous gérons 20.000 restaurants en France
avec 80 000 salariés et pour un volume
d'achat annuel de 2 milliards
nous réalisons un quart de notre chiffre
d'affaires avec les marchés publics et
dans les marchés publics il y en a une
bonne part qui est portée par les
collectivités locales au titre de la
restauration scolaire alors si je veux
évoquer ce sujet de l'inflation je pense
que le plus simple est de partir du
compte de résultat dans un restaurant
collectif
le coût d'un repas est composé à 40% de
des matières premières
ces matières premières elles ont connu
une augmentation de 20% entre janvier
2023 et janvier 2022 c'est un peu plus
que ce que vous pouvez voir en GMS où on
vous dit que les produits alimentaires
ont à peu près pris 15 % et pourquoi on
est un peu au-delà c'est parce que les
volumes d'achat la restauration
collective ne sont pas ceux de la GMS et
deuxièmement c'est que la restauration
collective utilise à peu près 85 % de
produits bruts dans ces cuisines et dont
finalement la part de produits agricoles
dans les produits que nous utilisons et
beaucoup plus importante parce qu'il y a
pas de marketing il n'y a pas de
marchandising sur un paquet de pâtes
quand on l'achète des pâtes on achète du
blé dur donc on est à plus de 20% entre
janvier 23 et janvier 22 et on commence
à observer une légère décrue c'est à
dire qu'au jour où à début juin où on se
parle aujourd'hui on n'est plus qu'à
17%. donc on voit que la décrue mais on
reste sur des niveaux d'inflation que
nous n'avons jamais vu depuis 40 ans le
deuxième poste qui constitue le camp de
résultat la restauration collective ce
sont les salaires pour 45% de la
structure du coût d'un repas sur ses
salaires
il y a un phénomène qui donne le la à
tout ce que l'on peut faire ce sont les
augmentations successives du SMIC qui
n'ont été que mécaniques sans coup de
pouce gouvernemental mais on en est
aujourd'hui à plus de 10% d'augmentation
du SMIC et donc le la branche porte le
dialogue social aux portes le dialogue
social et naturellement si on veut pas
tasser les minimas conventionnelles au
niveau de la branche on est obligé de
pouvoir tenir compte pour éviter un
écrasement de la grille de
l'augmentation des salaires sur le reste
de la grille et donc nous sommes encore
en discussion avec les partenaires
sociaux
actuellement avec une négo qui devrait
se terminer le 20 juin mais très
vraisemblablement nous aurons une
augmentation
en moyenne de la grille sur quasiment
les 9 échelons de la grille qui se
situera à 12% d'augmentation en 18 mois
donc on est sur 20% sur les matières
premières 12% sur les salaires et sur
les 15 derniers pour cent qui concernent
finalement les autres coûts la part de
l'énergie est très modeste puisque la
part d'énergie représente moins de 3% du
coût de la production et de la
distribution de ma repas donc c'est pour
ça j'espère ne pas être hors sujet au
regard de la commission qui nous invite
mais cette pinellement la part
énergétique c'est pas nous finalement
qu'il a qu'il a pilotant en tant que
consommateur d'énergie c'est plutôt un
effet inductif dans les matières
premières que nous achetons ou
effectivement vous l'avez vu dans le
monde de l'agriculture l'augmentation du
prix de l'énergie peut avoir une
incidence sur le prix des matières
premières que nous achetons alors une
fois qu'on a dit ça finalement comment
on a été capable de répercuter cette
inflation auprès des collectivités
locales il faut bien avoir en tête que
nous sommes en capacité d'augmenter nos
prix une seule fois par an contrairement
à beaucoup d'autres modèles économiques
vous pouvez vous voir mais quand vous
voulez nous c'est une seule fois par an
et il y a deux c'est toujours la date
anniversaire du contrat
il y a deux dates majeures c'est où le
premier septembre parce qu'on se cale
finalement sur les sur les sur l'année
sur l'année sur l'année de l'école et au
1er janvier pour des questions
d'exercices fiscaux 70% des contrats
voient leur évolution de tarifaire au
1er septembre les 33% au 1er janvier
la dernière fois qu'on a fait cet
exercice pour 70% c'était donc au 1er
septembre 2022 nous avons été en
capacité d'augmenter nos prix de 4,5%.
parce que c'est l'application mécanique
des formules contractuelles qui sont
dans les cahiers des charges cahier des
charges rédigés à l'initiative de la
puissance publique
on voit bien qu'on a un gap donc majeur
puisque vous avez vos charges qui
entravèrent augmentent de 15% et vous
avez vos prix qui augmente de 4 et demi
la marge de la restauration collective
les bonnes années avant impôt c'est 3%
. donc on arrive à une situation où 80%
des marchés publics sont déficitaires
si je regarde l'augmentation des prix
qui a été appliquée au 1er janvier elle
est passée de quatre et demi à 5,1 donc
on voit qu'il y a les gères je dirais
continuité dans cette progression de
l'inflation et la répercussion mais on
est extrêmement loin de la couverture de
l'augmentation des coûts subis par la
restauration donc ça un enjeu majeur
c'est un des entreprises qui se
désengagent de ce métier de la
restauration collective et notamment des
PME et de TPE qui ne veulent plus
entendre parler de marchés publics en
disant c'est trop risqué de jouer avec
ces gens-là
deuxièmement c'est les filières amont
qui disent ce n'est plus un débouché
possible et rentable et donc on commence
à avoir un amont qui réfléchit à se
désengager de la restauration collective
dans cette absolument dramatique au
regard de l'enjeu de notre souveraineté
alimentaire et de soutien que l'on veut
donner à l'agriculture française et
troisième élément
on sait qu'au bornes de la profession
hôtelier cafetiers restaurateur il
manque aujourd'hui 200000 à 250 000
salariés si nous ne sommes pas capables
d'avoir les moyens de maintenir la
progression des salaires le
développement des carrières par une
attractivité on se retrouvera les uns et
les autres avec de moins en moins de
gens qui veulent faire ce métier et j'y
vois même un enjeu de santé publique si
demain il y a plus de gens qui veulent
être cuistot à l'hôpital on pourra avoir
d'autres problèmes au sein de l'hôpital
donc en fait de la manière dont on va
gérer cette crise conjoncturelle elle
aura des effets structurels
ce que nous on a fait pour essayer de
soulager quelque part cette cette
pression que l'on doit répercuter auprès
des collectivités locales on a présenté
à l'AMF et notamment à au maire au
président l'isnard des pistes que l'on a
pu travailler pour essayer de permettre
collectivités de pouvoir
avoir finalement l'addition de reprendre
un terme de notre métier la moins la
moins douloureuse possible donc parmi
les postes qui ont été ou les pistes
pardon qui ont été évoquées pour
certaines catégories de convives c'est
le passage de cinq composantes à quatre
composantes et notamment pour les petits
des classes maternelles donc je pense
par exemple là aux enfants de 3 ans ou 4
ans ce que j'entends par composante
c'est entrer plat protidique garniture
fromage dessert et du pain voilà il y a
des collectivités qui ont fait le choix
alors soit tous les jours soit deux
jours par semaine de retirer une des
composantes sans que ça ne nuise
nutritionnel ni de la semaine ni des
quatre semaines de menu pour diminuer
finalement le volume de ce qui est de ce
qui est de ce qui est servi deuxième
chose qui n'a aucun impact sur le repas
en tant que tel c'est le conditionnement
c'est-à-dire que nous on a beaucoup de
cuisine qui livre les remparts dans des
restaurants scolaires tous les
restaurants scolaires de France n'ont
pas de cuisine bien évidemment et donc
on conditionne ses repas c'est-à-dire
qu'on met ses repas dans des dans des
plats voilà et donc selon que vous
conditionnez ou par 4 ou par 6 ou par 8
ou par 10 ou au kilo forcément vous
utilisez un nombre de conditionnements
qui contrairement différent et donc le
fait de diminuer le nombre de
conditionnements là aussi diminue
finalement le coût de la le coût de la
prestation troisième élément
le covid a pas mal perturbé nos
statistiques de fréquentation des
restaurants parce que les parents ayant
maintenant pris des habitudes un peu
plus aléatoires sur le nombre de jours
où ils ont décidé de faire du
télétravail finalement il y a des jours
où ils gardent leur enfant à la maison
et donc vous savez nous on se trompe à
peu près de 2 à 3% entre le nombre de
repas que l'on produit les nombres de
repas qui sont consommés mais vu que là
on cherche des centimes le fait de
d'avoir un prévisionnel de commande et
ça c'est marrant parce que quand on a
dit aux parents avant même que la crise
éclate comment vous voyez
l'investissement que vous voudriez
mettre pour avoir la meilleure assiette
possible pour vos enfants tout sont dit
il faut qu'on soutienne cette
trajectoire environnementale alimentaire
tout ce que vous voulez et donc pour
pouvoir la financer on est prêt à
regarder un peu les grammages de
diminuer la largeur de la gamme et donc
c'est là qu'aujourd'hui on a des
collectivités ils ont dit mais plutôt
qu'avoir trois entrées au choix ou deux
desserts en choix puisqu'il faut aller
jusqu'au bout du dernier convive avec ce
choix là si on diminue le choix
forcément vous produisez moins parce que
la marge d'erreur que vous vous donnez
vous avez pu à la produire et puis
troisième élément c'est on est prêt nous
parents à vous dire ben voilà le petit
pour moi la semaine prochaine il viendra
mardi jeudi vendredi et ça je vous dis
une semaine à l'avance de manière à ce
que vous n'ayez pas à gérer l'aléa de
lundi il sera là où il sera pas là voilà
et donc ça aujourd'hui ça faisait aussi
partie des pistes qui ont été travaillés
par les mers et certains avec des
schémas un peu coercitifs en disant sauf
bonnes raisons qui sera la maladie les
Orions ce que vous voulez bah si vous ne
nous prévenez pas vous serez facturé du
repas vous n'aurez pas consommé voilà
donc on est passé d'un système qui était
un peu
et Open je sais pas quoi à un schéma un
peu plus voilà il faut que
collectivement soit responsable des
choix que nous des choix que nous
faisons et puis après dans les autres
éléments il y a aussi des des livraisons
qu'on a pu faire
très tôt le matin c'est à dire
aujourd'hui les collectivités locales
demandent à peu près à toutes les
cuisines de livret tout entre 7h et 8h30
bon ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on ait
une concentration de chauffeur et de
camions pour qu'on soit tous à l'heure
dans toutes les cantines de France entre
7h et 8h30 si on nous autorise à avoir
les clés et de pouvoir livrer à 6h on
n'est pas obligé d'avoir deux camions et
donc on n'est pas obligé d'avoir deux
chauffeurs etc et donc ce sont des
choses là aussi qui touchent finalement
non pas du tout à la prestation en tant
que tel mais qui dans l'organisation du
service permet de dégager quelques
marges manœuvres mais soyons quand même
lucides et responsable ces marges
manœuvre ne peuvent représenter que
aller 15% de ce qu'on a à chercher mais
vu qu'on cherche tous des centimes et
que nous en tout cas on fait un métier
de sentinier et que je sais que la
gestion des collectivités locales elle
se gère quand même aussi à deux chiffres
après la virgule il faut qu'on se
saisisse de chacune de ces opportunités
et pour mettre un peu de trajectoire et
de visibilité
je ne sais pas quels seront les indices
applicables aux révisions de prix de
septembre et de janvier prochain mais vu
que vous êtes période peut-être en
période de construction budgétaire
je pense qu'au minima il faudra prévoir
5 à 7 % ne serait-ce que par
l'application mécanique des contrats
mais ceux qui peuvent se passer c'est
que vous voulez bien compris entre 5 et
7 c'est bien loin de couvrir ne
serait-ce que le point mort des
entreprises dès lors qu'il y a
reconsultation les prix de marché
aujourd'hui sont nettement supérieurs au
prix appliqué aujourd'hui et le marché
finalement par sa juste mise en
concurrence à des effets sur les prix
qui sont plus
inflatés que l'application mécanique
pour des raisons qui sont un peu longues
à expliquer mais en fait on a une
décorrélation entre la structure de coût
les augmentations de coûts et les
indices qui sont dans les formules de
révision de prix c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un travail qui est
mené avec l'adage à Bercy avec l'INSEE
pour avoir finalement des
mécanismes de révision qui soient plus
équilibré moins en denti pour couvrir
l'équilibre des contrats au bénéfice des
deux parties
merci beaucoup juste avant de passer
la parole à mes collègues peut-être
juste quelques paroles en écho d'abord
vraiment merci pour vos témoignages
extrêmement complémentaires
extrêmement intéressant moi ce que
j'entends de manière générale c'est la
culture de la sobriété
dans dans la consommation d'énergie mais
vous l'avez aussi dit Monsieur et
c'était extrêmement intéressant dans
l'offre que l'on propose notamment à la
cantine à leur même que l'on voit bien
qu'en restauration collective on a des
injonctions un peu contradictoires
puisque on a des obligations mais je dis
pas ça de manière négative des
obligations d'achat
d'approvisionnement en bio en circuit
court qui sont parfois un peu plus
coûteux et une exigence de parents sur
la qualité nutritive des repas qui n'a
rien à voir avec la fréquentation
familiale des McDo voilà est-ce que je
peux madame la président rajouter juste
un commentaire à votre propos
effectivement tout à l'heure quand j'ai
parlé de 20% d'augmentation c'est
Acadie équivalente ça veut donc dire que
c'est 20% non pas permis la montée en
gamme attendue par égalité et
aujourd'hui il y a même je sais pas si
je vais choquer l'assistance ici mais il
y a quasiment un arrêt sur image des
gallimes parce qu'il n'est pas possible
en même temps de supporter les 20%
d'augmentation pour avoir la même chose
que ce que j'avais avant et porter la
montée en gamme des gallimes dont tout
le monde reconnaît aujourd'hui que il
faut à peu près rajouter 40 centimes au
couvert pour arriver à aux objectifs de
la loi donc j'ai vu l'autre jour une
déclarations de marc-heno pour dire
voilà comment l'État doit exemplaire sur
le sujet puis deuxième point que j'ai
pas indiqué tout à l'heure mais qui
illustre quand même l'attention sur ce
sur ce métier là aujourd'hui 25% des
appels d'offres
lancés par les collectivités locales qui
vise à acheter des denrées alimentaires
pour les cantines scolaires sont
infructueux vous ne trouvez plus de
réponse dans un quart des marchés
d'éclairage alors on voit Monsieur le
Maire vous vous l'avez dit et vous
l'avez dit aussi monsieur
l'incident alors que moi je trouve
positif sur l'organisation
de la distribution du service ou de
l'approvisionnement vous l'avez bien dit
Madame que aujourd'hui sur les énergies
renouvelables et je pense qu'on est très
sensible à ça il ne s'agit pas de voir
des énergies renouvelables se substituer
à d'autres énergies mais par contre un
mixte d'approvisionnement
permet de lisser la consommation de
sécuriser en tout cas une partie une
partie du coup et l'évolution de
l'organisation dans nos dans nos
collectivités intéressantes et que
partout on sait bien que souvent les
progrès peuvent aussi mettre de la crise
qui nous laissent optimiser alors
ensuite moi j'ai
deux éléments monsieur le Président vous
l'avez cette volatilité et c'est
imprévisibilité alors je vous pose une
question un peu en vous demandant de
vous transformer en madame Yama est-ce
que la volatilité l'imprévie visibilité
sont devenus structurels ou est-ce
qu'elles sont liées à des événements
conjoncturels comme comme par exemple la
crise de l'Ukraine et puis moi j'ai été
très sensible à ce que vous avez dit sur
les fournisseurs alternatifs c'est à
dire à un moment on a on a pensé qu'il
fallait ouvrir très largement pour faire
simple à la concurrence favoriser une
offre élargie avec des fournisseurs
alternatifs et vous vous nous dites que
il y a une sorte d'insécurité sur les
fournisseurs alternatifs ce qui ce qui
n'est pas sans poser problème pour la
sécurité de l'approvisionnement et puis
je rappelle quand même que nos
collectivités sont pas très à l'aise
avec le métier de trader
que vous devez avoir et la notion de
articulations parce que on dit
aujourd'hui que l'eau est un bien commun
à un moment moi je suis pas soviétique
pardonnez-moi d'être un peu caricatural
et ça mais la sécurité de
l'approvisionnement dans les
collectivités quand on parle de
l'hôpital par exemple c'est un vrai
sujet donc comment on conjugue comment
on conjugue un peu tout ça et puis je
suis très sensible à ce que vous avez
dit sur les la stratégie multiplic vous
devez
mixer en quelque sorte le fixe et le
lise pour permettre de limiter
l'augmentation donc sont des sujets très
intéressants donc il y a trois demandes
de parole notre collègue Bernard delcro
qui prépare déjà la loi de finances j'en
suis sûr
Céline Brulin notre collègue Fabien
Genet et Muriel Jourdain
de par deux si vous êtes d'accord
Bernard puis Céline et vous ferez merci
madame la Présidente à dire mais le
temps nous est compté donc je vais me
restreindre alors j'ai une question pour
vous Madame la Directrice vous avez
évoqué largement les dispositifs qui ont
été mis en place dans la loi de finance
pour protéger les collectivités
boucliers tarifaires amortisseurs
électricité et filet de sécurité en fait
ce sont ces trois on avait prévu de
mémoire au budget c'est de l'ordre de 50
milliards pour financer ces mesures
est-ce que vous vous pouvez nous dire
aujourd'hui combien de collectivités ont
pu en bénéficier et quel montant ça peut
représenter je ne sais pas si vous avez
ces éléments en tous les cas nous ça
nous intéresse de comparer la réalité de
ce dont on peut bénéficier les
collectivités avec ce qui était prévu à
l'origine vous avez évoqué les C2E qui
est un dispositif intéressant malgré
tout je pense que sont aujourd'hui
encore mal connues et un peu compliqué
pour y accéder voilà il y a-t-il des
choses prévues pour pour permettre de le
rendre plus accessible et donc plus
efficace et puis Homère au maire de
savaine une petite question vous avez
indiqué que les vos dépenses d'énergie
avec augmenté si je me souviens bien d'à
peu près 10% du budget 1,6 millions
d'euros j'imagine que ça vous ne prenez
en compte que les dépenses directes sur
les contes d'énergie de de de des
mandats mais si on intégré évidemment
les effets induits notamment l'incidence
du l'augmentation du coût de l'énergie
sur les matières premières pour les
travaux etc on serait bien bien au-delà
ça serait intéressant d'ailleurs d'avoir
ces éléments on va pas les avoir comme
ça mais le coût réel finalement le coût
réel pour les collectivités en direct ou
induit de l'augmentation du coût de
l'énergie et ce que je voulais vous
demander sur ce Myon 6 alors vous aviez
pris un certain nombre de dispositions
pour réduire en quelque sorte
la consommation vous appelle les
éclairages publics moins de 300 -
300.000 euros et au final l'ensemble des
mesures que vous avez prises la semaine
de quatre jours etc l'éclairage public
par rapport à semi-6 vous êtes arrivé
finalement à économiser combien
et quand vous avez parlé de 30 ou 40 %
d'économies c'est en montant en euros en
quelque sorte ou en consommation voilà
j'avais ces quatre questions je veux pas
aller plus loin faut pas être trop long
merci Bernard notre collègue c'est une
brûlante merci présidente merci à tous
pour effectivement des exposés qui se
complétaient bien
et qui montrait que chacun déploie des
trésors d'ingéniosité dans la situation
c'est vrai que vous avez décrit comme
conjoncturel mais
[Musique]
en même temps il me semble que il y a
des choses qui vont rapidement avoir
leur limite
d'autant que vous avez expliqué les uns
et les autres que tous les efforts
déployés jouaient quand même sur une
petite partie des efforts à réaliser et
puis quand même vous avez tous dit que
peut-être que cette situation tendrait à
devenir structurelle en tout cas on peut
pas on peut pas l'évacuer et donc ça
mérite me semble-t-il de réfléchir aussi
à des mesures d'ordre plus structurelles
que tout ce que vous avez mis en oeuvre
les uns et les autres je pense par
exemple vous l'avez dit Monsieur le
Maire et vous l'avez dit vous aussi
Monsieur
le le coût de l'énergie va impacter les
capacités des collectivités à investir
et à investir par exemple pour mettre
leur bâtiment en situation de moins
dépenser de l'énergie il y a en ce
moment au Sénat une mission sur le bâti
scolaire la rénovation bâties scolaire
c'est 40 à 50 milliards d'euros
d'investissement à faire pour rénover
enfin pour faire la rénovation
énergétique évidemment que des
collectivités comme la ville de Saverne
qui voit un surcoût de 1 million six
même si elles font des efforts vont
avoir des difficultés donc voilà moi ça
concerne aussi l'industrie on a vu qu'il
y avait quand même un nombre conséquent
d'industrie qui avait suspendu leur
activité et je trouve que ce serait
assez délirant que il y a eu un soutien
pendant la crise sanitaire et qu'en gros
un certain nombre de nos activités
économiques s'écroule sur la crise
énergétique et donc dans les mesures
structurelles moi j'ai quand même envie
de vous questionner sur même si c'est
pas la réponse à tout
les tarifs réglementés parce que je vous
rejoins madame la Présidente l'énergie
c'est pas une marchandise tout à fait
comme une autre on envoie l'importance
aujourd'hui sur le marché européen de
l'électricité
parce qu'on est quand même dans une
situation un peu délirante en France où
on est soumis à la des constitutions de
prix qui correspondent absolument pas à
notre mix énergétique et qui nous
pénalise terriblement me semble-t-il et
enfin sur la reine puisque on a vu qu'il
y avait quand même des opérateurs qu'on
dit alternatifs qui n'ont en gros je
vais être très caricatural mais encore
que qui ont fait de la spéculation mais
à peine plus que ça pour
contribuer à l'oeuvre commune en matière
énergétique merci
beaucoup je vous propose de répondre
comme vous l'entendez à cette première
série de questions nous en aurons une
deuxième
merci pour vos questions je vais je vais
peut-être démarrer parce qu'il y a pas
mal de questions effectivement qui qui
concernent EDF alors sur le nombre de
collectivités je serai pas vous le dire
comme ça parce que je n'ai pas je n'ai
pas ce nombre je peux vous le trouver ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que nous
avons environ 400000 clients qui sont
concernés par qui ont renvoyé une
attestation conforme un peu moins de 400
000 en réalité mais mais on va arrondir
sur les marchés publics alors en fait
nous on regarde les marchés publics dans
leur ensemble donc dedans il y a
effectivement les collectivités mais il
y a aussi les bailleurs sociaux etc moi
j'aurais tendance à dire que c'est moins
de 10% de ce monde de ce de ce volume là
mais le chiffre précis je ne l'ai pas je
peux je peux le trouver
dans dans les les mesures que vous avez
explicité sur bouclier amortisseur filet
j'en ajouterai une qui est le sur
amortisseur parce que comme vous le
savez sur les TPE et Assimil és donc
moins de 10 salariés moins de 2 millions
alors chiffre d'affaires budget enfin ça
dépend un petit peu de l'acteur il y a
donc le surmortisseur qui avait été déçu
annoncé par le président de la
République d'ailleurs et qui consiste à
caper et à aplatir le prix si je peux
utiliser cette expression à 230 euros du
mégawattheure or hors acheminement toute
l'année maximum donc ça c'est quand même
une mesure forte
oui mais les collectivités font partie
de ce les petites collectivités ont
bénéficié de ce de ce voilà alors
ensuite on parle de structurelles et de
conjoncturelle bon c'est vrai que les
prix de marché alors encore une fois on
n'a pas de boule de cristal et moi je
m'aventure pas du tout à ça mais on ne
connaîtra probablement pas avant
longtemps des prix de marché tels qu'on
les a connus il y a quelques années à
une époque je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez en 2016 ou quelque chose comme
ça ils étaient descendus à 25 euros du
mégawater bon bah ça je pense qu'on a on
a fini avec ça et d'ailleurs
heureusement parce que les producteurs
ils font failli avec ça mais mais
néanmoins on est on est quand même
retombé dans des prix alors qu'il reste
élevés par rapport à il y a quelques
années mais qui sont quand même
nettement inférieures à ce qu'on a connu
au second semestre 2022 on était monté
souvenez-vous à 1000 euros du
mégawattheure fin août et puis on est
resté assez longtemps à 4 500 600 euros
du méga là aujourd'hui encore une fois
en forward de 24 on est autour de 150
enfin avoir de 26 on est autour de 100
donc on est je dis pas que c'est faible
mais on est quand même redescendu à des
valeurs plus plus modérées moi j'aurais
tendance à dire que les une façon de
faire face
vraiment comment dire une façon sérieuse
de faire face à cela il y a évidemment
tout ce qui est en place tout ce qui se
dessine sur le Market design toutes les
mesures qui vont être prises donc ça
bien sûr mais une façon qui est à notre
main qui est à la main des clients et à
notre main à nous fournisseurs et puis
peut-être à d'autres acteurs encore une
fois c'est l'efficacité énergétique
parce que tout kilowatt-heure non
consommé et gratuit en fait et donc ça
et quand vous disiez c'est les efforts
sont conduisent à des économies
marginales je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord parce que je vais vous donner
un exemple et je veux pas être trop
longue mais je vais vous donner un
exemple nous avons une offre qui
s'appelle pilotage intelligent du
bâtiment qui est qui est adapté
également aux collectivités
territoriales d'ailleurs nous nous la
vendons aussi collectivité pour gérer
alors vous parliez Monsieur le Maire du
thermomètre que vous promeniez avec le
thermomètre et en fermant les radiateurs
cette offre PIB permet en fait de gérer
automatiquement avec une interface
digitale très simple confort et
température alors ça marche très bien
pour des hôtels ça marche très bien pour
des écoles pour des gymnases etc bon et
bien nous avons observé sur les clients
qui utilisaient cette offre que il
pouvait aller en moyenne à 15%
d'économies quand même donc c'est pas
d'énergie donc ce n'est pas complètement
marginal parce que quand vous multipliez
ces 15% par le prix unitaire vous
arrivez quand même à des économies
importantes donc alors c'est des efforts
c'est vrai mais c'est important
s'agissant des industriels juste une
petite une petite incise lorsque nous
comparons alors je sais pas si ça va
vous consoler mais en tout cas ça
console ces industriels là qui sont en
compétition européenne quand on compare
les prix rendu site en France par
rapport au prix rendu site de leur con
de leur collègue et
concurrent européen et bien nous sommes
ex nous sommes beaucoup moins cher en
France en fait donc alors pour une
collectivité ça ceci n'a pas de sens
parce qu'effectivement elle n'est pas en
concurrence avec une collectivité
ailleurs mais pour un industriel c'est
quand même c'est quand même très
important un mot sur le tarif réglementé
de vente peut-être alors le tarif
réglementé de vente nous notre analyse
c'est que évidemment il faut une
conformité il faut qu'il que les
décisions pris soient conformes aux
règles européennes comme vous le savez
notre analyse mais encore une fois c'est
notre analyse c'est que
pour les
les entités je dis entité au sens large
les consommateurs éligibles au tarifs
réglementés de vente aujourd'hui c'est à
dire moins de 10 salariés moins de 2
millions ca budget etc et avec une
puissance souscrite inférieure à 36 kVA
ils sont éligibles au tarif réglementés
de vente d'ailleurs nous avons eu un
certain nombre de retours au tarif
réglementés de vente à l'occasion de la
crise énergétique
s'agissant des collectivités on en a eu
à peu près 20 000 pour vous donner une
ordre de grandeur 20 000 sites 20000
sites c'est pas des collectivités c'est
des sites dont 10% à peu près provenant
d'autres fournisseurs et 90% déjà chez
nous en off de marché donc je reviens à
cela nous pour nous notre analyse c'est
que étendre cette éligibilité de ces
acteurs là toujours TPE et assimilés
aux puissances souscrites supérieures à
36 Ava
vu de nous c'est faisable parce que
notre analyse et que ce ne serait pas ce
serait conforme aux droits européens
parce que le 36 Ava a vu de l'Europe n'a
pas de sens en fait c'est assez
franco-français le 36 avva donc en
résumé TPE et assimilé 10 salariés de
millions quel que soit la puissance
souscrite il nous semble qu'il est
possible et nous sommes plutôt nous
sommes favorables à l'extension du TRV
assez à ses entités là au-delà notre
analyse c'est que il y a une petite
incohérence avec le droit européen
mais c'est ta confirmé bien sûr
je regarde Monsieur le Maire de que vous
intervenez ensuite pardonnez-moi si nos
deux collègues peuvent poser leurs
questions et après chacun d'entre vous
aura un droit de réponse à la fois sur
cette deuxième série de questions mais
sur la première naturellement si cela
vous convient merci Monsieur le Maire
merci madame la Présidente oui monsieur
le sénateur les l'économie que j'ai
annoncé étant est en volume et pas et
pas en euros mais en gros pour
schématiser un petit peu on attend sur
le fameux million 6 donc tes 10% de du
budget de fonctionnement en plus
à peu près 30% d'économie financière
aussi grâce aux économies d'énergie
qu'on a qu'on a réalisé comme je l'ai
dit l'augmentation mécanique de la
fiscalité de par l'augmentation des
bases va y être consacrée quasi
totalement et nous comptons sur le
fameux
amortisseur de l'État là on a construit
le budget avec ce point d'interrogation
avoir 400.000 euros ou ne pas l'avoir
sur un budget de de 16 millions c'est
quand même quelque chose d'important et
avoir les questions très pointues qui
nous reviennent la DGFiP on a encore
quelques doutes sur sur notre propre
analyse j'espère que ces doutes ne
seront pas douchés parce que sinon on
aura on aura une vraie une vraie
dégradation de notre capacité
d'autofinancement
alors bouclier tarifaire c'est zéro dans
une collectivité comme la nôtre
puisqu'on a on a des puissances beaucoup
trop importantes ce qui est d'ailleurs
difficile parce que quand je discute de
cette de cette problématique au sein de
la communauté de communes on a beaucoup
de petites communes ils comprennent pas
mon ma difficulté parce qu'ils sont tous
au tarif bleu avec avec des boucliers
etc et c'est compliqué de le faire de le
faire ressentir et c'est compliqué
vis-à-vis de notre population aussi qui
heureusement bénéficie à titre
individuel de de ce bouclier tarifaire
et ils me disent Monsieur le Maire vous
exagérez beaucoup ben non on exagère pas
c'est une réalité nous n'avons pas de
bouclier tarifaires espérons au moins
que cet amortisseur reste une réalité
pour nous pour compléter à la question
de madame la sénatrice ce qui est clair
aussi c'est que toutes ces mesures
conjoncturelles elles doivent être mises
en oeuvre mais elles ont des limites je
dis souvent que les mères nous sommes
des les artisans de de l'action publique
et un moment il va falloir passer aussi
à une phase plus industrielle si vous me
passez la métaphore bien sûr il nous
faut diversifier notre mix énergétique
aussi de notre côté d'ailleurs nous
avons à Saverne lancer une délégation de
service public pour un pour un grand
réseau de chaleur avant même la crise
énergétique les
d'ici quelques semaines nous nous allons
attribuer ce marché nous comptons
beaucoup dessus c'est à peu près 40 % de
nos bâtiments qui devraient être
connectés à ce réseau de chaleur
j'espère que ça va au moins stabiliser
les les coûts et après bien sûr les
mesures d'isolation des bâtiments de
passage en LED etc c'est important mais
c'est un coût aussi important en
investissement nous si on voulait passer
en LED par exemple tous les éclairage
public c'est un coup de 2 millions
d'euros alors on le fait petit à petit
mais le temps que ce soit fait c'est
c'est compliqué je rajouterai une
dernière chose c'est que sur nos 90 m²
de bâtiment nous avons la chance et je
c'est une chance d'avoir beaucoup de
bâtiments historiques mais aller isoler
mon bureau du XVIIe siècle qui est
magnifique mais mais mais où il fait
très très froid en hiver ou le château
des Rohan du 18e c'est très compliqué et
c'est un gros d'ailleurs c'est c'est des
grosses batailles autre sujet je vais
pas l'ouvrir mais entre d'une part la
drague qui veut qu'on utilise que les
techniques des des siècles de
construction et et l'adréal qui nous qui
nous demande d'améliorer les
performances énergétiques c'est très
compliqué c'est un autre sujet mais il
faudra y penser aussi merci beaucoup
alors juste sur ce sujet il y a une
mission qui existe au Sénat sur comment
on gère la performance énergétique et le
patrimoine en disant faut peut-être là
aussi qu'on arrête d'être un peu
caricatural et de faire des bêtises sur
du patrimoine ancien donc si vous êtes
d'accord avec la méthode continue du
temps donc Fabien Genet et Muriel
Jourdain et ensuite naturellement je
donnerai la priorité en droit de réponse
à Monsieur pour nous et Monsieur jossa
c'est normal madame la Présidente est-ce
que je peux juste ajouter un petit un
tout petit point je voudrais apporter un
témoignage parce que ça ce qui me fait
penser c'est ce que vous avez dit sur
les réseaux de chaleur et vous avez
parlé madame de l'industrie il y a il y
a un nous avons réalisé des opérations
notre fidèle Dalkia réaliser des
opérations dans certaines régions qui
sont extrêmement intéressantes et je
voudrais les porter à votre connaissance
c'est la récupération de chaleur sur des
usines des process ou autres qu'on cette
chaleur on la réinjecte dans le dans le
réseau de chaleur de la ville voisine et
ça permet de chauffer plusieurs dizaines
centaines de logements et ça c'est
vraiment vraiment très important en
termes d'économie circulaire voilà je ne
prends pas mais vous êtes invité à
compléter vos contributions par écrit
vraiment si vous le souhaitez parce que
je suis conscient qu'on vous contraint
quelque peu donc Fabien je n'aime un
légendaire vous avez la lourde
responsabilité nous permettre de finir à
Fabien merci madame la Présidente tout
d'abord vous remercier pour
l'organisation de cette table ronde qui
me semble tout à fait pertinente et qui
permet de réaliser finalement un point
d'étape sur cette problématique
remercier les quatre intervenants pour
leur exposer et leur première réponse on
a bien compris que vous étiez finalement
quatre victimes de l'inflation à des
titres divers peut-être sur
l'électricité tout d'abord
je ne regrette pas d'être venu ce matin
parce que vous trouvez Madame la
Directrice à nos côtés pour faire
remarquer qu'effectivement le seuil de
36 kVA n'est pas dans les directives
européennes mais que c'est une
surtransposition argument que nous
avions fait valoir lors du projet de loi
de finance et lors de discussions de PPL
ici au Sénat nous espérons que avec
votre renfort ne pourront effectivement
faire progresser cette analyse et
obtenir effectivement
et vous l'avez très bien dit
l'inégalité finalement que pose toutes
ces mesures de soutien entre les
collectivités avec des seuils qui certes
là pour le coup sont de nature
européenne mais pas forcément très
lisible sur le terrain ça crée des
différences monsieur bien vous l'avez
dit très bien entre collectivités qui
sont parfois difficiles à explicables et
là aussi je pense que dans les
prochaines discussions parlementaires
nous devrons en tenir compte pour aller
droit au but madame la Présidente
j'aurais une première question sur
l'électricité sur l'énergie
parce que quand même beaucoup de nos
concitoyens se posent une question que
je voudrais relayer à cet instant c'est
tout de même ces prix parfois
exorbitants que nous avons connu dans
vous avez très bien expliqué la
formation des prix les dérives etc le
conjoncturel mais enfin tout de même
souvent contrairement à la restauration
collective souvent tout cela s'éloigne
du prix de production et donc il y a
quand même une différence entre le prix
de production et le prix de vente et
donc beaucoup de nos concitoyens et un
certain nombre de parlementaires se
demandent où passe l'argent et donc si
quelqu'un ici a une réponse de où est
étalée l'argent ça peut nous intéresser
deuxième question vous avez dit Madame
la Directrice ainsi que vos voisins de
table que finalement au-delà de 2025 on
a très peu de visibilité sur
ce que peuvent être les perspectives
d'évolution de ces coups or les
collectivités locales doivent
aujourd'hui arbitrer sur un certain
nombre d'investissements et diocèse il
les investissements en matière
énergétique sont prioritaires
aujourd'hui mais la question c'est sur
quoi faut-il investir j'ai présidé mon
syndicat départemental d'énergie pendant
6 ans entre 2014 et 2020 à l'époque on
me disait et je disais dans mes
interventions que le gaz par exemple
c'était génial le gaz pouvait devenir
vert et donc il fallait absolument
développer cette énergie et puis
maintenant on nous dit qu'on n'a rien
compris du tout et que le gars s'est
abominable surtout s'ils viennent Russie
et donc il faudrait passer au tout
électrique mais là aussi nos concitoyens
et les maires se disent tout passer à
l'électrique au moment où finalement il
y a une volatilité des prix de cette
énergie c'est un peu contre-intuitif et
donc finalement j'aimerais peut-être
vous relancer sur cette question des
perspectives et donc comment arbitrer
les nécessités d'investissement et dans
quelle direction faut-il aller et pour
terminer madame la Présidente
peut-être en réaction à ce que disait
Monsieur le Maire effectivement saluer
toutes les initiatives prises sur le
territoire par les collectivités pour
faire des économies mais vous l'avez
très bien expliqué c'est quand même
monsieur le Président du Syndicat de la
restauration collective le disait aussi
c'est parfois un peu au détriment de la
qualité du service public et donc la
vraie question c'est jusqu'où peut-on
dégrader ce service public c'est la
question que je laisse en plus sport
madame la Présidente je vous râle merci
beaucoup donc Muriel Jourdain notre
collègue du Morbihan merci madame le
Président merci à tous nos intervenants
comme vous avez demandé d'être rapide je
vais être brutal
j'avoue je suis profondément agacé par
le terme permanent déjà je sobriété
enfin je pense que personne ne sort de
chez lui en laissant le robinet allumé
ni la lumière allumée en tout cas pas
les gens qui payent leur facture et
c'est la même chose dans les mairies et
de tout temps les mers ont fait des plus
fort d'ailleurs ce qui explique
aujourd'hui Monsieur le Maire de Saverne
c'est comment il complète les efforts
qu'il a déjà fait pour pouvoir réduire
au maximum les factures enfin on est on
est tous à peu près responsable on fait
tous à peu près ça même s'il existe
encore des marges de manœuvre qui
parfois ne défendent pas de la mairie
parce que souvent ce bataille avec les
associations qui augmentent le chauffage
et qui refusent de détendre en partant
bon je crois qu'on a tous on a tous la
même expérience de de mer ici donc ça
c'était une une petite une petite
observation qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
contre vous car je ne crois pas que ce
souris qui viennent lancer le débat sur
la sobriété j'avais plusieurs questions
mais je vais me limiter à une regarde du
temps a-t-on à un moment calculer le
retour d'investissement sur les
économies d'énergie qui peuvent être
liées aux travaux dans les bâtiments
qu'on peut faire ma collègue Céline
Brulin disait que on évalue des travaux
par dizaines de milliards on fait des
travaux d'investissement est-ce que
véritablement on aura une compensation
en termes d'économie de fonctionnement
d'énergie c'est une chose dont on a
beaucoup discuté avec Monsieur Béchu et
je posais une question qui lui a pas plu
mais j'aimerais bien avoir une réponse
un jour est-ce que véritablement on ne
nous pousse pas à faire des travaux qui
n'auront pas à retour sur investissement
c'est la dernière question mais les
fondamentale c'est la pertinence et le
juste investissement je veux pas
déborder parce que voilà donc je vous
propose messieurs qui avaient été privés
de parole tout à l'heure d'abuser si je
suis dire dans ce temps contraint donc
je vous laisse
oui quelques mots
sur le prix de l'énergie comme je dis
tout à l'heure
il y a un fait qui est inévitable c'est
que c'est un marché que ça reste un
marché et que et que ça restera à
marcher mondial ne serait-ce que parce
que le gaz ben il est important en
France principalement de Norvège mais de
manière à
accessoires beaucoup malheureusement de
la Russie avec les difficultés qu'on
connaisse c'est ce qui explique
d'ailleurs la violence du choc et
minoritairement de l'Algérie donc quoi
qu'on le veuille c'est un marché et les
ventes se feront beaucoup marginales ce
qui fait que lorsque vous pouvez vendre
au coup de margin avec vous êtes
producteur vous gagnez de l'argent et
que lorsque vous êtes pas quand vous
produisez pas vous-même la matière
première et bien vous vendez avec vos
propres coups de production d'où
l'importance de ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure sur le fait de bien acheter dans
ce contexte s'agissant des éléments
structurels vous avez tout à fait raison
de dire que tout le Bayard est un
élément qui qui va être fondamental à
long terme c'est le passage la
substitution
d'énergie électrique des carbonées aux
énergies fossiles ça c'est un élément
qui est compliqué à évaluer parce qu'on
sent bien qu'il y a une pression vers
une énergie plus décarbonée ce qui tire
aussi c'est un peu la chanson quand ça
dictoire à la hausse les coudes
d'énergie et mais dans le même temps il
y a les ralentisseurs notamment dans les
domaines des véhicules quel élément
assez stratégique parce que nous vendons
aussi des bus électrique et ça elle
élément l'élément structurant ça va être
aussi qui va peut-être ralentir un peu
les choses c'est la rareté des métaux
rares qui viennent dans la composition
des batteries donc tout ceci nécessite
des économies et des analyses
économiques croisées qui sont assez
compliquées à faire donc ça c'est le
premier point donc je pense qu'il faut
quand même vivre avec l'idée que c'est
un sujet que ni les autres maîtriseront
complètement d'où l'intérêt de tout ce
qui a été dit je pense par vous-même et
et de l'offre qu'on peut faire nous même
pour contribuer à faire des économies
intelligente en matière d'énergie ils
savent on est sur des quelque chose de
structurel et de long terme et en plus
qui était qui est intelligent en termes
de décarbonation donc je pense qu'il
faut pas avoir des tadames pour trouver
toutes les solutions qu'on peut dans ce
domaine voilà le dernier élément que je
voudrais dire c'est que je voudrais pas
qu'on comprenne de mon propos que je
suis opposé au fournisseur alternatifs
les fournisseurs alternatifs ont permis
une ouverture la concurrence qui est
l'émergence d'acteurs
intéressants qui ont permis d'élargir le
marché la seule chose que qu'on peut
dire c'est que on a vu deux cas de
figure des
enfin il y a quand même un sujet lorsque
ces fournisseurs ont pris d'énormes
contraints par rapport à leur propre
capacités financières voilà là on a un
sujet et notamment il y en a un et qui a
disparu de la circulation qui a pris des
contrats colossaux et les ont emportés
en prenant des risques spéculatifs sur
les prix et le résultat c'est que il a
été complètement
cisaillé par présentation qui avait pas
prévu considérable des cours il est
sorti du décor bon le deuxième cas qu'on
a vu qui qui s'est mal passé c'est un
autre fournisseur dans le domaine du gaz
qui lui s'était correctement couvert
mais
contenu de l'incertitude des prévisions
et des variations consommation liées à
température etc ces trucs oblige
d'acheter sur le marché spot à des prix
extrêmement élevés et ça ça suffit quand
l'ampleur inédite des variations mettre
dans le rouge mais bon ils sont nés
sortis mais tout ceci a conduit
d'ailleurs à une recomposition du
paysage et aujourd'hui il y a pas mal de
ménages qui a été fait c'est ce qu'on
peut dire dans ce secteur et donc le
système c'est un peu un peu brutalement
mais c'est quand même un peu régulé
voilà ce que je voulais ajouter sur ce
sujet des des fournisseurs alternatifs
je vous remercie
je
vois qu'il est 57 je vous promets dans
58 j'ai perdu 2 secondes non c'est juste
pour répondre à notamment à la à
l'interrogation de la sénatrice brûlant
sur est-ce que c'est structurel ou
conjoncturel
je reviens sur mon compte de résultat je
suis un peu obsédé par ça mais forcément
les salaires entre les liens et
heureusement il y aura jamais de retour
en arrière nos collaborateurs ont tous
pris 12% d'augmentation de salaire il y
aura pas c'est pas comme l'huile d'olive
et heureusement je pense à madame la
sénatrice à son pardon pour l'huile
d'olive mais voilà j'aurais pu prendre
une autre huile mais c'est pas si vous
êtes en face de moi que l'idée m'est
venue mais voilà en tout cas il y aura
pas de retour en arrière et c'est bien
normal et il faudrait pas que les
salaires des gens qui ont fait le choix
de la restauration collective soit la
variables d'ajustement budgétaire d'une
transition environnementale agricole et
alimentaire donc ça c'est le premier
point et le deuxième je suis pas non
plus Madame Irma mais si on regarde de
manière très macro on va être de plus en
plus nombreux encore pendant un certain
nombre d'années présent sur cette terre
deuxièmement les conditions climatiques
font que on voit qu'on commence à avoir
des baisses de rendement et
troisièmement on est tous d'accord je
crois pour dire on doit en France
soutenir l'agriculture française et on
ne peut pas pour faire ça allez taper
dans le portefeuille des agriculteurs
dont vous connaissez aussi bien que moi
le nombre d'agriculteurs qui trouvent
pas de successeur le nombre de
connaissez tous les chiffres y compris
les plus dramatiques donc je pense que
structurellement on devra s'habituer et
pour moi vous allez dire c'est un
plaidoyer prodemo mais j'en suis très
heureux à payer plus cher son
alimentation
merci beaucoup c'est le juste prix
dernier mot pour conclure d'abord
vraiment vous remercier pour l'intérêt
de vos contributions ce sujet de la
restauration collective qu'on explore
encore peu mais qui est majeur et je
crois ce que vous avez dit alors
monsieur le Président de Gap et en lien
avec la question de ma collègue les
collectivités ont besoin d'être
accompagnés pour réussir cette
transition et prendre les bonnes les
bonnes décisions et la pertinence des
investissements parce qu'on connaît des
investissements disent proportionnés qui
au final sont un peu décevant au côté
fourchette et n'apportent pas
d'économies ensuite moi ce que
j'apprécie c'est que on subit des
dépenses donc on dit comment dépenser
moins vous avez raison la meilleure
énergie c'est celle qu'on ne dépense pas
c'est comme les déchets toutefois je
pense que l'on voit l'intérêt de
l'intelligence et de l'innovation qui se
développe à la fois dans les dans les
énergies mais aussi dans les modes
d'organisation donc moi je trouve que
c'est un côté positif qui nous conduit à
ne jamais désespérer de la nature
humaine notre capacité de non seulement
résilient mais surtout à innover et à
progresser et je pense que la leçon que
nous retenons aussi c'est celle de
l'enjeu d'un mix énergétique et d'une
capacité de notre pays à pouvoir
bénéficier d'une certaine autonomie dans
notre approvisionnement
je vous remercie et vraiment nous
serions très heureux si vous avez des
contributions complémentaires à nous
adresser avec plaisir et veillez nous
pardonner
de vous en malmener